hello everyone I hope you're all having
an excellent Sunday now the big match
Croatia vs. Denmark the football match
starts in half an hour so I thought I'd
make the video now and upload it after
the game as I don't think I'll be I'll
have enough time to publish it before
it's a game I don't know if you remember
a couple of videos ago I mentioned that
there was a tournament of Legends being
played I implied that they are
determined displayed between Anatoly
Karpov your haenyeo Torah Alou Bermuda
voyage and Anatoly this year and they
will play a couple of rapid games and a
couple of Blades games and this is one
of the games that was played in this
tournament so before I show you the game
we do have a nice photo challenge so
here it is I don't have a lot of
information as their website isn't all
that all that great but David Lada sent
me a couple of photos and all of the
games that were played in this
tournament so far and now whoo-hoo he's
the gentleman next the Karpov in this
photo that is the first question and
there you can see in Karpov checking out
a lot of book the thinkers are checking
himself in the book so for one point who
is the gentleman the grandmaster next
Karpov on the right and who is the
person in the photo book next the Karpov
in the photo book for some extra points
so there we have it best of luck to
everyone and also we have a very nice
very nice photo of Lada and Karpov there
very nice Soviet style photo of insane
high quality if I do say so myself
so hope you enjoyed that and I don't
have a photo of this game but I do have
a photo of Turin Karpov playing I
believe this is from the blade section
so here
Torres white Karpov is black but in this
game this one I'm showing you is from
the rapid section here Karpov has the
white pieces so let's check it out
we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 and c6 Knight
to f3 and Bishop to b4 the BOGO Indian
defense
Bishop to d2 blocking we have Queen to
e7
and now g3 preparing to the mcat or the
light square Bishop Knight to c6 Bishop
to g2 worship
capture Sunday to Knight captures and d6
now
Karpov castles Tori plays a5 we have E 4
E 5 and now D 5 Karpov doesn't miss an
opportunity to grab more space Knight to
be 8 and now Knights to e 1 preparing f3
to solidify in the center Bishop to g4
attacking the Queen f3 comes and now
Bishop back to d7 and here as you can
see the bishop is on d7 the pawn is
controlling c6 it's not all that easy
for Tori to develop this night of course
he could go something like a 6 going for
for for c5 so Karpov first Queen plays
Queen to b3 attacks the b7 pawn and here
be success play there is an interesting
pawn sacrifice with the knife to a6
now after Queen captures black could
castle and then of course rook to b8
would be the threat but after Queen
moves still rook to b8 comes and after
Queen to c3 then c6 comes and black
would have some compensation for for a P
for the pawn due to such nice activity
but there is no real advantage in doing
it of course capturing upon here would
lose the Queen immediately now after a
knife to before between here and now 98
will pick up the Queen or Queen will
grab rook
either way white would lose a queen here
but Tory goes for b6 simply solidifies
the position we have Queen to c3 and now
h5 and it's a very interesting now you
can see Tori played a 5 and h5 this is
something you can't do very often in
chess as usual your king will have to go
either to the Queen side or to the Kings
side but now it's not all that likely
that story will ever castle
we'd have h4 now comes Knight 286 gb3
knife to h7 and now Tori would very much
enjoy pushing g5 at the break open the
position maybe put some looks on g8 and
h8 and start an attacked word scarf of
scheme Karpov doesn't allow it he goes
f4 and now Tori simply repeats Knight to
f6 as now Karpov did weakened the g4
square a3 preparing b4
and now night the c5 b4 comes we have
knife to a for attacking the Queen Queen
to d3 and now we have castles
so Tory gives up on the idea of
attacking the Kings I didn't he does
castle himself we have nice two a three
by carp of Knight g4 and now rook 8c one
preparing c5 at at some point rook F to
e8 cart off goes Knight to g5 now comes
f6 kicking away tonight Knight to h3 and
now comes Queen to f7 here Tory gets the
idea he wants to play Queen to g6 but as
you'll see the idea won't go go as he
planned will have a brush up to f3 and
here you could play a lot of ideas a
capture some before is an idea b5
immediately with a breakthrough is an
idea but story repeats his idea place
Queen to g6 and this is basically a
blunder of a pawn so Karpov immediately
pushes f5 attacks the Queen we have
Queen to h6 and a bunch of characters on
g4 pawn captures and knife to f2 perhaps
it wasn't a pawn blunt or perhaps Tori
perhaps it was a pawn sacrifice as as
you'll see in the game Tori will get a
lot of activity for the pawn but it I'd
say it was a pawn wonder Queen to h5
defending the pawn but now comes Queen
e2 and now there is no way to defend the
pawn here you could go something like
King to h8 here make room for the room
to come to g2 but here actually rook to
f8 displayed so now the dew point can be
pushed forward the f6 bone is defended
and here we have Queen captures on g4
and Tori exchanges Queens Knight
captures on g4 a capture some before a
capture some before and now nice to be
to Tori is now down upon but his pieces
will be more active here you could go
rook a1 immediately challenged a Torres
rook on D on the open a file but then
you get 93 then the b4 is under attack
and the current Karpov doesn't like this
so instead he plays rook to f3 not
allowing the night to go to d3 but it
allows rook to a2 we have c5 Bishop to
b5 and now see captures on d6 see
capture son d6 and now rook to c2 now
Karpov is still up upon but the the
b-pawn is not all that strong we have
looked to a one-trick King - H - nice -
d3 threatening nice nicely one forking
the rooks we have rook to e3 and here
rook F to a8 doubling up on the a file
immediately capturing the pond that
doesn't work for black because of rook
to be - now attacking the knight and the
bishop behind the night if the knight
moves of course and after rook to a to
rook to b3 rook captures rook captures
and now Bishop to e2 attacking the
undefended night and g4 rook captures
Bishop captures and hero captures and v6
white still keeps his extra pawn and
sure should win the same game
so after rook to e3 not immediately
going for the pond but first rook f8 and
here of course now the same idea
wouldn't apply and Karpov has to go a
careful Karpov must play Knight to f3 he
has to give up the pawn after rook here
rook protects rook which rook to e2 now
rook to a4 and now there is no way to
protect the before pawn but you have to
allow this rookie three and now rook
captures it's the only way white can
proceed playing this position you have
to give it up at least to activate your
pieces but here after Luke f8 car police
came to h3 he doesn't allow rook to a2
to be played with any checks or painting
ideas here rook to h1 check is played
and now carp of the only choice for
Karpov here is King to g2 you have to
allow ideas like 91 and then after King
captures Knight captures going for more
exchanges attacking the rook attack from
the pawn but there's no way around this
here fortunately have fortunately for
Tory
instead of King g2 carp of late night -
h2 and this is actually a blunder that
that loses the game but fortunately for
carpool now Tori miss
the idea here Tory played rook eight a
one he wants to go and grab this beep on
immediately and you know it's as they
say you you know what's what's the
saying you can't see the forest because
of a tree or something like that he goes
for a pawn and he misses an even greater
idea because after nice to h2
I feel free to pause the video here and
find the idea
Tory missed it's not very difficult I'm
pretty sure you're all gonna see it
immediately it's it's a that was all the
posted on Facebook and Twitter saying
that it was a case of you know mutual
hallucination that even after the game
was over there when they were analyzing
it they didn't find it this idea but a
lot of says that he saw the idea and
that you know but he was reluctant to
say anything does missing his chance to
you know tell tell the legends what did
they missed but you know that happens
here for those who who founded
congratulations
are you are a great tactician and for
those who just want to enjoy a show here
nice to have to check simply checking
the king is not allowing the Kings to go
to G for King has to go back and now of
course comes ro captures on h2 King
captures an IG for check check the King
wins the rook you have to move the King
now knight Knight captures on e3 white
black is up a whole piece winning the
game easily but after night to h2 Tory
misses this he plays rook a to a-1 like
we said going after the b-pawn 9 TD to
f3 we have rook to be one attacking the
pawn rook to d2 and now comes a nice
capture Sun before so Tori grabs grabs
the pawn and it's not that Tori is now
worse or anything he's even better he
equalized in material and his position
is much more active but you know if you
can win a game instantly you should
definitely do that
we have g4 by Karpov and now comes Luke
H to d1 rook H to d1 now Tory blunders
the game Taurus position is excellent
here he should go king f7 improve the
position you know just keep everything
keep everything going but he plays rook
H
he won and now Karpov capitalizes on
this mistake simply rook captures rook
captures and route to b3 winning winning
material of course the bishop to f1
check
Knight captures rook captures and here
of course if you capture then black can
capture here but Karpov late King to g2
and Toure resigned the game well if you
resign well of course you do have to
move the rook after rook moves route
capture Sun be done before his coming
and now white is up a whole piece that's
easily winning the game so yeah after
working to g2 Tory resigned the game and
like I said they're not really doing an
excellent job with the website as I
can't even find any information if this
tournament has finished but I I did get
like I said all the pigeons from David
Lauda and here are the official
standings I mean they are standings but
it doesn't say if the tournament is over
this it says that the tournament is
still being like held on 1st of July and
I don't know if there are any games
placed today so unfortunately I do not
know the tournament is over but if it is
and the chances are it is but I will
have to confirm this as you can see in
the rapid section of the tournament
carpel one four point story one new boy
which two and a half and the past year
of four and a half so Anatole was here
one to wrap it a section of this
tournament but in the blitz section it's
actually Karpov who won the blade
section one whole point ahead of Anatole
was here
Tory got three points and d-boy h5
points in blitz so if these are the
final standings it appears that Anatoly
Karpov won the tournament half a point
ahead of uh Natalie was here I followed
by a double middle watch and then your
hand near Tori but yeah I will I will
have to confirm this and as this is the
tournament of Legends I will show
probably another game and hopefully I
will have more information for you if
any of you do have any information
regarding this tournament you know of
course feel free to share in the
comments so we can all you know enjoy
the information I would like to thank
Peter Rangel of Stefan Hein Mike Emery
golf and the Dale Hamilton for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
probably going back to 1936 kappa blanka
and botanique series and you know let's
check out a Croatia vs. Denmark starts
in 13 minutes see you soon